4 septembre 2012 charlotte en caroline
du nord nous sommes à la convention du
parti démocrate américain
un événement presque aussi glamour que
les oscars eva longoria mary j blige ou
encore localiser jeff bridges le tout
hollywood se déplacer jusqu'ici dans un
but bien précis mais que s'assurer que
les gens battent et qu'ils votent pour
barack obama et la mobilisation des
stars obama on a plus que jamais besoin
depuis son premier débat en demi teinte
face à son adversaire mitt romney
les deux candidats à la maison blanche
sont au coude à coude dans les sondages
le résultat s'annonce très serrée le
plus important dans cette campagne ce
sont les célébrités qu'à tous ceux qui
apportent une part de rêve une part de
glamour à hauteur d' ida contribué à son
élection
les stars feront elles gagné obama cette
année encore rien n'est moins sûr en
tout cas il aura besoin d'un peu plus
que de strass et de paillettes pour
reconquérir le coeur du peuple américain
quatre ans après son élection le bilan
du président sortant a déçu et
l'obamamania des premiers temps est bel
et bien retombé
comble de l'ironie certaines célébrités
qui le soutenaient auparavant comme
barbra streisand ou matt damon l'ont
ouvertement critiqué dans les médias
êtes vous satisfait de la manière dont
obama a gouverné jusqu'ici non alaoui
m'daghri qui je crois vraiment pas
compris son boulot un désamour qui
risque de lui coûter très cher d'autant
que wall street lui a également tourné
le dos à cause de sa gestion de la crise
du coup pour gagner
barak a tout misé sur les stars
d'hollywood à la fois pour leur pouvoir
de séduction mais aussi et surtout pour
leur aptitude à collecter des dons le
plus important après le glamour c'est
l'axé la galette
parce que hollywood sert à remplir les
caisses des candidats lors de
championnats du monde c'est georges et
plus les entre cloud mais obama tout a
commencé en 2006 avec l'engagement de
l'acteur pour le darfour
depuis ils sont
amis et s'affichent ensemble dans les
médias un allié de taille comme nous le
confirme jean valls l'un des premiers
présentateurs de jt afro américain de
l'histoire
la force de george clooney c'est qu'ils
attirent l'attention des gens si vous
moi entrons dans une pièce et disons
j'ai quelque chose à dire la plupart des
gens présents répondre on est alors
quand c'est george clooney qui entre
dans la pièce et qui veut dire quelque
chose
les gens l'écoutent et canclaux mais
décide d'aider son ami à lever des fonds
pour soutenir sa campagne il ne fait pas
les choses à moitié
en mai dernier il décide d'organiser
chez lui un dîner avec des célébrités
comme salma hayek ou robert downey
junior et la bonne idée c'est que
n'importe qui pouvait y participer
moyennant un petit don et après tirage
au sort une vitrine de noël qui a rempli
sa mission bien au delà des espérances
de la star en une soirée clooney a
récolté plus de 15 millions de dollars
daniel d'osier et conseiller en
communication et membre actif du staff
obama for america
il nous dévoile les coulisses de ce
dîner ce qui est important à retenir
fait qu'un grand parti mais je crois que
la moitié est venue des peptides dans en
dessous de 200 dollars bon évidemment il
y avait des grands chaque et du gros
chèque
il y en a eu davantage puisque d'autres
stars ont essayé de faire aussi bien que
d'orge le président obama et michelle
viennent dîner chez moi portas mais tout
le monde ne s'appelle pas de georges au
final sarah jessica parker et anna
wintour ont récolté 4 millions et demi
de dollars ce qui n'est pas si mal
quant à beyoncé et jay-z ils ont réussi
à glaner quelques 4 millions de dollars
supplémentaires
mais est ce qu'une telle connivence
entre les people et le pouvoir serait
possible en france
l'amérique c'est le pays du rêve
américain et du rêve hollywoodien qui ne
font qu'un donc entre le show business
et la politique c'est le lot story chez
nous entre le cheveu la politique c'est
je t'aime moi non plus donc c'est très
différent et les stars ne servent pas
qu'à remplir les caisses les petits
soldats de barak ont une autre mission
rallier le plus grand nombre d'électeurs
à sa cause avec son éventail de
célébrités
il arrive à toucher toutes les couches
de la population contrairement aux
républicains première cible visée
l'amérique profonde et notamment les
swing states ces états américains
traditionnellement indécis et qui
peuvent faire basculer une élection
après de george clooney c'est au tour du
bost himself bruce christine à bientôt
40 ans de carrière de faire passer le
message des lions président barack obama
donnons-lui quatre ans de plus
l'audience est captivé et ce qui est
bien avec barak c'est qu'il pense à tout
le monde pour convaincre les jeunes de
voter il sait s'entourer sa carte
maîtresse la ravissante scarlett
johansson aux dernières élections j'ai
enfin il droit de voter toute seule
comme une grande année elle était très
efficace pour faire à venir des jeunes
et et pour écrire pourquoi l'enjeu était
important de voter quand pour la
première fois
réalisons le président barack obama
mais le vote sur lequel compte tout
particulièrement le président sortant
pour gagner cette fois ci c'est celui de
la communauté latino avec une politique
d'immigration qui prônent la fermeté
les républicains se sont mis à dos cet
électorat une erreur monumentale que
bara compte exploiter une fois de plus
ils misent sur des stars comme jennifer
lopez ou eva longoria pour faire la
différence
je suis vraiment motivé pour parler à la
communauté hispanique ça me remplit de
joie mais en même temps il faut vraiment
les pousser à aller voter eva on va la
chercher parce qu'elle et latinos
parce que elle va pouvoir séduire les 16
% d'américains qui sans latinos qui vont
faire la différence dans ces élections
16% soit 52 millions de personnes un
chiffre énorme et une stratégie que le
camp démocrate espère payante
les stars se sont donc tous mobilisés
derrière leur président mais au final il
semble que la célébrité qui agit le plus
en faveur de barack obama soit en fait
michel merci première dame c'est vrai on
est michel de tout notre coeur des
présidents elle est incroyable le
président bédié souvent hélas on
remercie dieu tous les jours de draps
voix rencontre est elle peut lui rendre
plus accessible surtout au niveau humain
un peu d'humour cela ne fait pas de mal
dans une campagne
l'aura de michel est telle qu'elle est
plus populaire que son président de mari
69 % de sympathisants à travers tout le
pays contre seulement 56 % pour barak
avec elle
il espère cette fois-ci rallier le vote
des femmes à sa cause et pour parvenir à
ses fins rien n'est trop beau
dernier coup d'éclat en date un petit
tweet amoureux pour leur anniversaire de
mariage qui à attendre et le monde
entier en quelques secondes
il y a 20 ans aujourd'hui j'ai épousé
l'amour de ma vie et ma meilleure amie
bon anniversaire michel alors les stars
feront elles la loi au pays de la
bannière étoilée résultats du scrutin
dans une semaine